Hey guys, Uh, it's Kayla back with another video
So the topic of today's video is being yourself being yourself can be hard
And it's like aren't I always being myself
and yeah for sure but being yourself is like not changing yourself to impress someone else a
Lot of people, like, call me quiet or shy or whatever
But I'm not quiet.
Most quiet: Kayla Day
I don't talk a lot at school, but if people talk to me and stuff
They'd find out that I'm like really funny and cool and talkative.
By the way, I like your shirt a lot. It's like so cool
What?
I said one more week of eighth-grade right yeah, that's crazy. Yeah, uh-huh
Okay, so growing up can be a little bit scary and weird.
we will begin to explore these changing bodies of yours
It's gonna be lit
As always make sure to share it and subscribe to my channel
gucci
I think you're so cool, maybe you just need to put yourself out there a little. - I need to stop eating with you.
You said I could say one thing!
I'm really like nervous over time try really hard not to feel that way, but you just need to face your fears
And let people know the real you
Can I just grab my phone? Gotta charge it. -yeah, I mean sometimes I charge it too. m- my phone
Just cuz things are happening right now doesn't mean they're always gonna happen. -what was in there? -just sort of my hopes and dreams.
Right.
I was a complete mess when I was your age. -really? -eighth grade is the worst!
You never know what's next and that's what makes things exciting
scary
And fun
when did you get snapchat? What year?
Fifth grade.
fifth grade? What?!